[Music]
on this Monday night crisis in Brazil
Riders ransack Congress and the Supreme
Court refusing to accept election
results the parallels to the January 6th
attack in Washington
remarkable recovery NFL star Demar
Hamlin is back in Buffalo a week after
collapsing during a game
and the mother of a potentially
life-saving invention the Ontario woman
using her head to help young six
cyclists
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin tonight in Brazil after what's
been described as a failed assault on
the country's Democratic institutions
security forces are now restoring calm
after the worst attacks since the end of
Brazil's military dictatorship they
stormed and ransacked government and
court buildings on Sunday supporters of
jair bolsonaro Brazil's far right former
president who was narrowly defeated
believed that election was stolen though
there's no evidence to back that up
hundreds of rioters were rounded up
today put on dozens of buses and
detained for questioning at the same
time prime minister Justin Trudeau
touched down in Mexico City for a summit
with the Mexican and American Presidents
the so-called Three Amigos Summit will
focus on North America but all three
leaders condemned the riots in Brazil
and pledged their support for Brazil's
democracy political violence in such a
big and influential country is deeply
worrying and has Echoes of what happened
in the U.S two years ago Eric Sorensen
has our top story tonight
it was a night of violence unlike
anything Brazil has seen since returning
to democratic government almost 40 years
ago all three branches of government the
Congress the presidential Palace and the
Supreme Court were stormed by supporters
of former president jair bolsonaro who
has not accepted the results of last
October's election police in the capital
of Brasilia have detained more than 1200
people many taken by bus to be held and
questioned
president Lula de Silva's emergency
decree put Federal authorities in charge
as police regained control damage was
extensive but this morning Lula was in
the presidential Palace meeting with his
cabinet showing the elected government
is still in place bolsonaro who was
close to former U.S president Donald
Trump is in Florida and reportedly now
in hospital he posted that invasions of
public buildings are outside the rule of
law prime minister Trudeau and the
presidents of the United States and
Mexico issued a joint statement prior to
their Summit that the three countries
condemned the attacks on Brazil's
democracy and on the peace peaceful
transfer of power many Brazilians
condemned the attacks
you don't need to break anything he says
accept the election results there is no
kind of Brazilian Embrace of the big lie
like you had in the United States Brazil
is the world's fourth largest democracy
but has teetered on instability a
military coup in the 1960s ended
Democratic elections for more than 20
years and the country remains deeply
divided on the right and left and
between rich and poor it's a more
fragile democracy right so this is very
concerning because it shows kind of how
vulnerable
the current government is many in the
west have high hopes for Lula
as a climate believer who's promised to
preserve the Amazon rainforest and as a
counter to right-wing populism in that
part of the world what Lula needs to do
is what he's been talking about doing
um which is to try to raise up a lot of
the people within the Brazilian economy
and society that have suffered a tent
city with bolsonaro supporters has been
the center of peaceful demonstrations
for weeks but after Sunday night's
Rampage even this non-violent form of
protest is being dismantled by Brazilian
Security Forces Eric Sorensen Global
News
the parallels between what happened in
Brazil and what took place two years ago
in the U.S Capitol in Washington are
obvious an attack on Democratic
institutions a huge security breach law
enforcement heavily outnumbered at the
start the riots in Brazil were much
bigger than at the U.S Capitol but as
Jackson prosco reports they appear to be
inspired by what happened in Washington
a near-carbon copy of the attack on the
U.S Capitol the storming of Brazil's
Congress followed the same Playbook with
a mob fueled by social media lies about
a stolen election carrying banners
telegraphing conspiracy theories about
voting machines it was very clear that
the germ of the idea had been planted in
January 6 and was brought back to Brazil
the warning signs were all there
ousted Brazilian president jair
bolsonaro has long been described as the
Donald Trump of the tropics the 2x
leaders are friends bolsonaro has been
taking advice directly from former Trump
strategists like Jason Miller and has
the backing of longtime Trump adviser
Steve Bannon a central figure in the
global far-right movement and the attack
on the U.S Capitol all hell is going to
break loose tomorrow
Bannon has been cheering on the rioters
in Brazil as Freedom Fighters using his
podcast to push lies about election
fraud in Brazil very Stark warning to
Maga and to uh to all the Republicans of
the games that are being played uh in
these elections you have large numbers
of Pro Bowl scenario supporters who have
been fed a steady diet of conspiracy and
misinformation and disinformation as
bolsonaro takes refuge in Florida there
are questions about whether the violence
may not only have been inspired but
planned in the U.S this will be a
question for the Brazilian investigation
two years after the attack on the U.S
Capitol election denialism and political
violence May stand as a new and
dangerous American export
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
now to the summit of leaders from Canada
the U.S and Mexico among the issues
expected to loom large at The Summit in
Mexico City is energy policy as David
Aiken reports contentious issues on the
agenda could test just how friendly the
meeting of North American leaders will
be
prime minister Justin Trudeau lands in
Mexico for talks about climate
immigration trade and improving
people-to-people ties I think it is
important for for for Canadians to know
that Mexicans are very interested in
Canada but Trudeau and U.S President Joe
Biden also want to address a major
dispute over Mexico's energy Market they
say the Mexican president Andres Manuel
Lopez obrador is violating North
American trade agreements by giving
control of the energy Market there to
Mexico State energy companies I know
that both President Biden and I are
going to be you know fairly clear with
with President Lopez obrador that this
this needs to be understood Lopez
obrador believes his policy is a matter
of national sovereignty he has a view of
Mexican energy that goes back to Lazaro
cardness in 1934 right who nationalized
the oil that's just his view of what
Mexico should be Trudeau though will
make a case for free trade on behalf of
Canadian firms which have already
invested 13 billion dollars in Mexican
energy projects projects that create
jobs back in Canada I understand he
wants to put more of an emphasis on the
state-owned energy companies but it has
to be done in a responsible way in a way
that understands that he's a part of
NAFTA and he has to abide by those rules
and many in Mexico will be on Canada's
side there is a huge concern in Mexico
about what is happening in the in the
energy sector and the investments from
Canada Trudeau met Monday with members
of Mexico's business Community a
business Community Keen to court more
Canadian investment because there is a
lot of interest and they are trying to
push in inside of Mexico to help the the
the
government to understand what Canada and
Canada's businesses needs from Mexico's
policies and regulations separately
Trudeau and Biden will have their own
one-on-one meeting Tuesday morning just
before the summit formally gets underway
David Aiken Global News
Ottawa
it has been decades in the making the
Canadian government has finally
finalized a deal to replace this
country's aging Fleet of cf-18 fighter
jets the agreement to buy 88 F-35
warplanes is an about phase for the
liberal government prime minister Justin
Trudeau has said in the past it wouldn't
happen because of concerns over costs
Mackenzie gray reports on what's changed
now
after years of debate it's wheels up for
the F-35 the federal government choosing
it as Canada's Next Generation fighter
jet the F-35 is a modern reliable and
agile fighter aircraft the defense
department will pay 19 billion dollars
to buy 88 f-35s but over the Jets
30-year life cycle maintenance cost
brings the total to a staggering 70
billion the first four planes will be
delivered by 2026 with the entire fleet
being sent by 2034. I think in the end
the government made the right decision
it's good to see them finally start
moving forward and taking the formal
steps we need to take to actually start
getting modern airplanes into the
service of Canadian Air Force the new
jets are the most advanced on the market
replacing the Aging cf-18s the
candidates use since 1982 but it was a
long path to purchase the f-35s in 1997
Jean crit chance signed up for a
development program allowing Canadian
businesses to help build the jet Stephen
Harper signed a deal to purchase the
F-35 in 2010 but Justin Trudeau vowed to
pull out of the contract a liberal
government will also do what the Harper
conservatives
ought to have said years ago we will not
buy the F-35 fighter jet
but after winning the 2015 election
Trudeau changed his tune the Liberals
purchased Australian super Hornets to
prop up an aging Fleet and opened a
competition that led to today's purchase
the aircraft has matured
and we see now that many of our allies
eight countries in particular are using
the F-35 former Chief of the defense
staff Tom Lawson believes today's
announcement sends the right message to
the International Community I think the
thing to keep the eye on today is Canada
now looks more serious uh as an ally and
as a defense partner the next big
challenge training pilots on the new
Jets that's set to start in 2026 but in
the interim the Canadian government will
continue to spend hundreds of millions
of dollars keeping the cf-18s in combat
shaped Donna and they'll be over 50
years old by the time the f-35s are
ready to go
I remember it well Mackenzie gray and
Ottawa thanks there is more good news
about the recovery of NFL player Demar
Hamlin who collapsed and went into
cardiac arrest on the field a week ago
the Buffalo Bills player has been
released from the hospital in Cincinnati
he's flown back to Buffalo he's still in
the hospital there but doctors say he
has been walking and eating and he
appears to be neurologically completely
intact they say there's no reason to
believe he won't continue his path to
recovery they credit the quick action on
the field including CPR and
defibrillation for saving his life after
his heart stopped
Hamlin received Immediate life-saving
Care here in Canada the husband of a
mother of three who died in a hospital
emergency room is demanding answers
37-year-old Allison holthoff became ill
on the morning of New Year's Eve her
husband took her to emergency he says
they waited more than six hours to be
seen by a doctor while her excruciating
pain became worse by the time she began
receiving care it was too late
and I guess there was a small chance we
could break it into an or
and there was a small potential chance
but
the odds were not in a favor it was more
likely that she was going to die
in the Cold War
the Nova Scotia Health Minister says the
department is investigating holthoff's
family has not yet been provided with
autopsy results
there's a warning for Canadians about a
scam that has stripped people of
hundreds of thousands of dollars the
Nova Scotia Securities Commission says
people receive unsolicited text messages
directing them to click on a
cryptocurrency trading site advice is
then offered through a secondary
messaging platform like WhatsApp and If
someone transfers funds the scammer then
shows fake Returns on the investment
when the victim attempts to withdraw
those funds the scammer disappears and
then resurfaces is someone offering to
recoup the losses for a fee at this
point the scammer has access to the
funds and the victims personal
information such as Bank Account Details
the commission is warning people not to
reply to unsolicited messages
Western Australia's devastating flooding
coming up the hundreds left homeless
plus the pledge for Pakistan still
struggling after last Summer's disaster
[Music]
at least 280 people in a remote area of
Australia's Outback have been forced
from their homes after a massive flood
the crisis in the Kimberly region was
sparked by a severe weather system which
brought a Year's worth of rain to some
areas in just a matter of days
Australia's prime minister has promised
to help repair the communities ravaged
by the floods and Emergency Services
Minister says it has been the worst
flooding in Western Australia's history
the International Community has promised
more than 12 billion dollars to help
Pakistan recover from devastating floods
that figure came out of a U.N conference
on rebuilding efforts and covers just
over half of the estimated 21 billion
needed in the short term
I am deeply frustrated that global
leaders are not giving this life for
this emergency the action and the
investment it requires
because words are not enough
without action climate catastrophe is
coming for all of us
Pakistan is expected to come up with the
rest of the recovery funding the U.N is
calling for major changes to the
International Financial system to allow
low-income countries to get adequate
funding from wealthier Nations after
disasters at least 1700 people were
killed eight million others displaced
from Pakistan's flooding in September at
about 5 million are still living near
stagnant flood waters
potentially life-saving invention next
the Canadian mother bridging safety and
inclusion
[Music]
whether you're riding a bike a
skateboard or a scooter helmets can
protect you from serious head and brain
injuries but if you wear religious
headwear on a daily basis it's not easy
to find a helmet that fits for years
sick adults and children have struggled
with whether to make safety the priority
over their religious beliefs when
participating in some activities and now
as nitu garcha explains a mother in
Ontario has come up with a solution that
means no compromise is necessary
so we're gonna open it up and now you
put it on Tina Singh is holding what she
hopes will be a solution for parents
like her all over the world once two
finger spaces above the eyebrow the
mother of three boys designed this
helmet created specifically for sick
kids who keep their hair in a top-not
bun and a cloth covering called apatka
they don't need Mom to change the way
that they've tied their hair or do
anything different for them they can
just put it on and go the colors for
this launch are these ones here so after
about two years of testing and multiple
iterations Singh has released what she
calls the first safety certified
multi-sport helmet specifically designed
for sick kids it's a part of our my kids
identity right it's a part of the
identity and who they are she says the
helmet is certified for kids over the
age of five for use with bikes in-line
skates kick scooters and skateboarding I
was put in the position of you know
being an occupational therapist who
works in the area of acquired brain
injury but not having a helmet that fit
my boys properly all activities that
weren't a safe option for her
adventurous boys ride a bike jump off
the ramp with it now in the production
phase and sales set to launch soon in
Canada the boys are excited about not
only the product
it's different colors or sizes but also
being able to do activities safely like
other kids their age I don't think she's
gonna say anything now that we got this
the conversation around helmet safety
for sick adults has resulted in other
inventions like this tough turban made
of bulletproof material as well as
helmet exemptions in some provinces but
Singh says this is the first time she's
seen a product focus on kids who wear
patkas this is not meant to cover a full
turban full to Star anything like that
this is meant for kids who need that
protection while participating in sports
and Singh says her mission is to improve
the inclusion diversity and safety of
kids in sport I would love to make one
for hockey because it's been in such dim
demand from people once they heard about
this saying it would be really great
because a helmet is mandatory for hockey
and our kids want to participate and she
hopes this is only the beginning of
product diversity in the market to
reduce barriers for kids like
herscha Global News
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's here
in Canada are these bison sculptures
that want to skiwin Heritage Park just
north of Saskatoon we'd love to see your
Canada please email it to viewers at
globalnational.com and thanks for
watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
foreign
[Music]